whrpflicht würden Sie sagen nur Frauen
nur Männer ich würde die Bundeswehr
natürlich komplett öffnen für für Männer
und Frauen
aber ich wird sie in der Pflicht bei den
jungen Männern belassen warum ich glaube
dass das
also erstmal ist es ist es schneller
umsetzbar zum zweiten auch glaube ich
dass dieses Argument das immer
herrschte sch ja die ganzen Strukturen
die ganzen Strukturen zu organisieren m
für Frauen eine Verpflichtung würde ich
nicht machen weil ich finde das ähm in
der unterschiedlichen lebungs ung der
unterschiedliche Akzente sind es war
immer die Begründung warum man das nicht
gemacht hat und schneller zu
organisieren ist es für junge
Männer